[Music]
[Music]
all right quickly a preface if you want
to talk about this this is an open
source project and one of our big goals
right now is to build community so
please feel free to tweet I'll beg you
please tweet and if you have questions
you can also if you're like going to bed
tonight and thinking hey that talk was
interesting I forgot to ask something
you can tweet to add Apache kudu or @t
lib con which is me or of course mailing
list and all that but some people like
Twitter alright so he already did the
poll it sounds like a few of you know
what kudu are kudu is but many of you
don't so this is a kind of marketing
diagram this is the only marketing II
kind of thing in this talk showing where
kudu fits into the Hadoop stack I'm
guessing many or most of you are Hadoop
users almost everybody here pretty
familiar with a dupe at least vaguely
familiar
okay so Hadoop is this big ecosystem
full of different pieces of software so
often we talk about using Hadoop we
actually mean using a bunch of different
open-source projects together that
collectively make up the Hadoop
ecosystem and this diagram is this kind
of showing this idea where you have a
bunch of different layers of the stack
and within each layer you have a lot of
different open-source projects so each
little box is probably at least one
maybe two or three different open-source
projects and the bottom layer of this
diagram is the storage projects and up
until last year the two main storage
options for Hadoop or HDFS and HBase and
who do fits in at that same layer so
it's not a new you know processing
framework it's not a new you know data
engineering framework it's a storage
component and of course it's a storage
component meant to work with the rest of
the stack just trying to set the stage
of where it fits and it's also of course
open source Apache License part of the
Apache foundation so you can look at the
code and use it however you like
so before I get into a lot of details on
what to do actually is I wanted to give
a little bit of a history of why we
decided to build CUDA you saw in the
previous slide there's a lot of
different components in the Hadoop stack
and we often have community users saying
like there's actually too many stop
adding components I was too confusing
with all these animals running around so
we kind of have to justify why should we
add one more animal
in case you don't know by the way a kudu
is this antelope like creature in Africa
they have really cool of vertical
stripes which will come in relevant
later all right so if we take those two
storage options that I mentioned earlier
HDFS and HBase and plot them on this
graph this is more of an mba graph
rather than like an engineering graph
because there's no numbers that went
into it is just like quadrants and on
the y axis here we have analytic
performance and the x axis has the
online random access performance and
we've plotted HDFS and HBase against
these two dimensions and if you look at
HDFS it's very high on this analytic
performance axis so what do we mean by
analytic performance this means
ingesting a lot of data so you're
storing large amounts of data and then
running workloads that will actually
scan over large amounts of that may be
the entire data set or an entire day's
worth of data maybe an hour worth but
you're not looking up an individual
record you're not trying to update one
record and read one record you're
looking at aggregate kind of analysis
and HDFS is excellent at that you can
load this data in at pretty much the
same speed that your hard disk can write
you can read it back out at the same
speed that your hard disks can read
you're basically not limited by anything
except your own ability to write the
analytics but on this x-axis it's pretty
far on the Left which is the slow side
meaning it's not so good at random
access there's no concept of indexing
built into HDFS there's no ability to
update an individual record it doesn't
even have the idea of records it's just
storing big files of course your files
can have records inside them but HDFS is
not at all aware of what it's storing so
it's really good for some applications
and cloud era and everybody else
continues to use HDFS we continue to
work on it but it has some areas that
it's kind of lacking and on the bottom
right we have HBase again a really
excellent system that we continue to
invest in and it has pretty much the
opposite characteristics it has very
efficient random access so you can
insert one row you can update one row
all these things are a millisecond kind
of scale Layton sees very low latency
but if you actually load a large data
set into HBase and try to do one of
these analytic workloads meaning running
a sequel query or a big ETL job or a
spark machine learning you find the
performance is actually pretty bad
compared to what you think the hardware
should give you you might only get 5 or
6 megabytes per second per core which is
much much less than the abilities of a
spinning disk much less newer faster
storage so a lot of customers are happy
with one a lot of customers are happy
with the other if their application is
either just analytic or just online but
there's a ton of workloads that actually
need some of both so maybe you have a
mostly analytic app but then you need to
go and retrieve individual records to
understand more about whatever user you
analyzed or you need to update or delete
as things change and then on the HBase
side you might have an online
application serving a website but you
want to actually perform analytics over
that same data set and not a copy and
synchronize to different storage options
so there's this big gap in the middle
it'd be nice if we had something that
could do both pretty well so the
surprise here of course kudou is gonna
go in that red box and the design goals
of kudou are to be high throughput
similar to HDFS for these analytic
workloads maybe it's not quite as high
up as HDFS but it's you know pretty good
you're not making a really big trade-off
and then compared to HBase again not
quite as far to the right as the
specialized system HBase for random
access but milliseconds scale random
access latency so pretty good maybe a
small trade-off there pretty good and
the main thing here is you can have one
system that handles both use cases
reasonably well we're not trying to be a
faster HDFS or a faster HBase we're
saying this is much simpler because we
can do both workloads well enough that
it really makes your life much better
and the data model is very much like a
database so it has tables and columns
and schemas and the kind of things you'd
be familiar with from post graphs are my
sequel and the idea there is it makes it
very easy to run things like analytics
because you understand the data model
you've got fairly clean data you don't
need to go tell everybody
these this is how you should interpret
these bytes everything is kind of set
out for you so we support sequel by
means of using a sequel engine on top of
kudu so Kudo itself doesn't speak sequel
but you can run Impala or spark sequel
in the future probably hive and presto
all these other sequel options can read
data from CUDA but if you prefer no
sequel especially for the kind of online
applications we also have Java C++ and
Python api's so you can read or write
ROS kind of like you're using Cassandra
or HBase or one of these knows equal
stores so the other goal for why we
built to do was to take advantage of the
changing hardware landscape so we
started the project in about 2012 and
looked at the current hardware and
looked up the trends of where hardware
was going and kind of did this analysis
and the first thing that's really
relevant for storage is spinning disks
becoming less popular compared to solid
state disks particularly for random
access for these big analytic
applications spinning disk is still
predominant it's much cheaper on a
density basis meaning you get more
gigabytes per dollar
but NAND flash is getting cheaper and
cheaper every year and for random access
the performance per dollar is much much
better because the single random access
is on the order of maybe 100
microseconds
unnhhh and flash versus maybe 10
milliseconds on spinning disk so it's a
hundred times faster maybe it's twice as
expensive but it's a lot better price
performance ratio so that's the existing
generation of solid state as NAND flash
and just announced last summer is this
new technology called 3d crosspoint has
anybody here heard about 3d crosspoint
no ok I'm about to blow all your minds
3d crosspoint memory is again a new
technology a flash entirely different
physical process from NAND flash and
it's about a thousand times faster than
the current generation of flash so we
had something that was 100 times faster
than disk and now we're making it a
thousand times faster again so it
performs almost like memory you have
this stick that you put in your dim slot
it's got a terabyte of a persistent
memory meaning you load and store to it
at normal load and store operations like
assembly code and it's persistent like a
disk this is going to completely chain
the way we designed storage software
because we no longer have this idea that
memory is this ephemeral thing is going
to go away and disk is a slow thing
that's really expensive to read and
write we have a thing in between now
maybe not quite as fast as memory but
it's persistent so this is going to
really change a lot of the trade-offs
but how we design software the other
kind of trend here is just a more linear
Moore's Law kind of equation where Ram
is getting cheaper every year if I look
back I join cloud era about seven years
ago and our customers were mostly
running about 16 gigs of ram on a box
and now almost all of our customers when
they're deploying new hardware are
getting at least 128 gigs probably 256
for a lot of applications if you go on
Amazon you can buy a terabyte ram just
rent the instance by the hour so big Ram
is becoming pretty cheap and
cost-effective so the takeaway here is
that storage is no longer the main
bottleneck for designing these systems
the main bottleneck now is going to be
CPU especially when you're looking at
random access because it used to be the
random access was 10 milliseconds away
it's gonna be so expensive to go do that
disk seek let's spend all the CPU we can
to avoid doing random disk seeks let's
try to sequential eyes all of our i/o
because sequential writes are so much
better and this train is just different
the the trade-off has changed we're now
we're saying this storage especially 3d
crosspoint is so fast that we'd rather
avoid CPU cycles and do more storage
access versus before we'd say let's
spend all of our CPU to avoid storage
access and this really impacts the
designs of the systems we're building so
if you go back to the 2006 BigTable
paper BigTable is kind of the precursor
to HBase this paper talks about how they
do a lot of work to avoid disk seeks
because everybody knows disk seeks are
massively expensive but now that's not
the case that design doesn't make as
much sense anymore for next-generation
hardware so all of this kind of led us
to say well we could you know spend more
time trying to micro optimizations EIN
rethink how these storage systems are
built based on the next generation
applications and the next generation
hardware
texts alright so that explains why we
decided to build a new project now I
want to get into some details on what
credo actually does how it works so the
one sentence explanation is that it's
scalable and fast tabular storage it's
kind of all you need to know this is the
elevator pitch the drilling down a
little bit
scalability it's designed to scale like
the Hadoop ecosystem scales so that
means thousands of nodes in a cluster if
you need more performance you just add
more nodes and the performance should
scale pretty much linearly with the
number of nodes that you're giving the
cluster so far we tested 275 nodes at
Cloudera we've got a test cluster that
we ran it on that doesn't mean that it
broke when we got to 300 or something
this is just what we ran and it worked
it was fine it didn't show any problems
of you know
creaking at the ends or something it was
working okay fast we mean millions of
random miles per second and on a per
node basis multiple gigabytes per second
of sequential throughput so if you're
doing a sequel query the second number
is really important how fast can we just
turn through the data and compute the
aggregate or feed the the actual rows
into your SPARC job to do some machine
learning how quickly can we just shuffle
this data to the client and we're
looking at multiple gigabytes a second
because the storage now gives us
multiple gigabytes a second a single
flash drive can give us three gigs a
second so for a CPU bound that's gonna
be a problem so we've done everything to
make it as fast as possible specifically
for that workload and last the tabular
part I mentioned this already but just
to review it's a sequel like schema so
this means you have a finite number of
columns which is very different than
HBase or Cassandra we actually know when
you create a table here are the columns
here are the types and this is part of
where we get our performance we can do a
lot of tricks based on knowing that a
particular field is an integer or a
boolean that we wouldn't be able to do
if we just saw everything as bytes of
course big data is always changing you
need to be pretty agile as the previous
presenter was talking about adding
columns dropping columns is important so
we've made that very fast that's a
constant time operation in CUDA
essentially it's metadata to add another
column or drop a column so even if you
have a petabyte large table it should
complete in a couple of seconds and no
SQL is popular so I talked about a
sequel like schema but we have a no SQL
like API so you can use that API to
individually look up or update or insert
one row and this is super nice if you're
trying to integrate with another system
that's ingesting your data you can just
use your natural programming skills and
insert rows super easy so sometimes we
say no SQL is actually an O SQL meaning
not only sequel so we have both the
sequel options and these no sequel api's
all right so I wanted to talk a bit
about use cases and architectures I
imagine a lot of people here are more
data practitioners data engineers and
want to see how might this fit into your
own architectures and your own use cases
so the single sentence explanation is
that it's good for use cases that need
simultaneous combinations of these two
different access characteristics
sequential access and random access if
you're only doing sequential probably
not a good fit if you're only doing
random probably go with one of the
existing no sequel databases like a
Sandra or HBase whatever but if you have
some combination of the two which a lot
of applications now do who do might be a
good fit so a couple examples the first
being time series time series is pretty
broad so I'll focus in on the first
example here streaming market data so I
was in New York about two weeks ago
talking to a couple of hedge funds who
are interested in credo and they've got
exactly this problem they're getting in
market data from maybe five or ten
different data providers so New York
Stock Exchange and Nasdaq and Bloomberg
and Reuters and all these people are
feeding them streams of data and they're
coming in as the event happens somebody
makes a bid or purchase that event
arrives within microseconds to their
system and they want that data to be
immediately ingested because they're
trying to make important decisions for
their business like should we execute a
trade if they're doing automated trading
or does this kind of this transaction
look fraudulent maybe
I need to actually stop transactions
from this particular trader who works
for me
who's doing insider trading before the
SEC gets involved so all these things
rely on analyzing the data that's very
very recent you don't want to wait until
the next day bulk load yesterday's
market data and then try to make a trade
you'll definitely miss the window for
when that trade is effective so that
covers inserts and scanning the data
that's just been inserted and lookups to
a certain extent - you might need to go
look up past information for the same
stock in order to make a trade or a
decision so what about updates you might
think this data doesn't get updated it's
just a log of what happened in truth I
was surprised to learn this updates are
scarily common in a financial industry
because these market data providers are
giving you ticks of data and then
occasionally they'll call you up an hour
or the next day and say hey sorry we
sent you bad data yesterday we got the
currency wrong on all those trades you
need to take all the values we sent you
yesterday and divide them by 70 because
it was supposed to be US dollars but we
sent you Japanese yen and you wouldn't
think this happens but it actually
happens with alarming frequency so the
ability to easily update the data on the
fly is super important as well and that
rules out a lot of more static logging
based systems that don't have any
concept of updates so the second main
category here is online reporting and
this looks more like a traditional data
warehouse type workload where you're
saying that I've got a bunch of
customers and transactions maybe web
accesses I'm doing traditional reporting
workloads where I'm joining the two data
sets against each other computing
aggregates etc maybe you want to analyze
how your newest ad campaign is doing if
you put up a new AdWords campaign you
want to understand is that effective for
the people using your site and people
used to be fine with hourly or daily
bulk loads but more and more people are
expecting real-time analytics so they
can react quicker if they put up a new
AdWords campaign within three minutes
they should know is as effective or am I
wasting my money and the businesses of
the future are the ones doing this the
best if you're doing this faster than
your competitors making decisions faster
then you're gonna be more competitive in
the marketplace so more and more
companies want to get to this real-time
streaming ingest into the data warehouse
workloads
so people actually do build these kind
of pipelines today these aren't new use
cases for the Hadoop ecosystem this is
an example architecture diagram kind of
distilled from what I've seen that a lot
of our customers at Cloudera I don't
know if anybody here this will probably
look familiar so we have on the top left
some incoming data so this might be your
market data providers if you're in
finance or your web server generating
logs if you're more of an Internet
company and that data streams in maybe
through a system like flume or Kafka or
scribe or fluent D there's a number of
different options and it arrives into a
system that can handle real time
streaming inserts so typically in the
Hadoop ecosystem this is HBase it might
be something like Cassandra or my sequel
or Postgres it could be any number of
choices but the main thing is that it
can handle these row by row inserts as
the data arrives but if you try to run
your analytics directly on this system
remember it's not the fastest it wasn't
really built for running sequel
analytics so people have cron jobs that
periodically dump the HBase data into a
better format like Parque so Parque is a
file format that's very very fast for
analytics particularly sequel or SPARC
things like that so now you've got your
Parque files which are nice and
efficient and you've got some job which
is gonna insert those park' files into
your hive data warehouse or some kind of
data warehouse directory so that you can
combine this data along with all your
historical data because you don't want
to just analyze the last five minutes
you want to analyze all time or the last
month so you have these metadata
operations to insert it into your hive
warehouse and then great you can run
your reporting requests against that so
every five minutes you dump in a new
little Park a file and you're doing fine
for a couple of weeks maybe a couple
months and then all of a sudden three
months later you realize your analytics
have gotten really slow and you do some
analysis why and it turns out hive is
not very efficient when you've got a
million you know ten megabyte files
you're trying to analyze it's much
better if you have larger files so you
end up writing another cron job which
takes ten or fifty of these little small
files merge them together concatenates
them into a big file you try to do this
little switcheroo thing where you
the 50 old files insert the new big file
and hope that when you're doing this you
don't have a query running at the same
time because maybe it'll get an error
because you delete something under it
maybe you'll see all the data twice if
it actually picks up the new data and
the old data so this stuff is really
error-prone it can be built you end up
maybe with locking systems on top too
and a lot of complexity maybe there's a
maintenance window where you do this at
night so finally you're happy and you've
got your reporting request you've got
your big files and then you get one of
these data correction events or somebody
may be a customer in Germany calls you
and says they need to cancel my account
and they have a law in Germany that says
that if you cancel your account you
actually have to go and delete their
data completely remove their log data
and that's super hard to do now that
you've got these big park' files because
you've got one customer in the middle of
this file who's got a log entry so
you've got to go rewrite all of your
logs to get rid of this one customer and
you've got more pipelines and it's super
inefficient to rewrite everything in
order to remove this data so basically
this is a mess anybody who's built this
it can be built it probably takes five
or six engineers to keep it running on a
daily basis as really fragile probably
takes months to build so the idea with
kudou is not that we're gonna do
anything faster the idea is we're gonna
do it easier so now we just have one
system and on the left side incoming
data can be inserted row by row as it
arrives and then you can immediately run
your queries your spark jobs your sequel
queries your point lookups whatever you
have against that same data store so you
no longer have any cron jobs you no
longer have to have engineers worrying
about what's getting swapped out when
you no longer have to think about
metadata and partitions in the same way
and if you get these late data changes
where you need to go delete something or
update something you just use the same
API you say update it super simple so
people who are coming to Hadoop and
seeing this and you fear like a
relational database background you kind
of see this and say like a big whoa of
course I can say update or delete on my
database that's obvious that's what
databases do if you're coming from the
Hadoop background this is pretty amazing
because you can't do that on the static
storage of HDFS well
three or any kind of file system like
abstraction so again the idea here is
just much simpler architecture in order
to achieve real-time availability of new
data and fast analytics on that data so
I want to share actual real use case
I've got my phone here this is a xiaomi
phone if you don't know it they are a
big mobile phone manufacturer in China
the world's fourth largest in the world
they're expanding to to India and I
think other countries as well over the
next you know year or two a really
amazing company they're about five years
old and already doing like 10 billion in
revenue pretty cool stuff
so they've got a ton of customers
they've got I think 800 million plus
customers now and whenever you use this
phone and you're using one of their
online services you can think of it sort
of like Apple or you use your iPhone I'm
not just using a device you're also
using iCloud and iMessage and maybe
Apple Mail and you know photo sharing
all these different things so same with
them they've got all these online
services and the customers are using
their phones interacting with these
services and the experience the users
have on the phone is really important to
their business if a user has a bad
experience they may switch to another
mobile phone provider and he's a really
really competitive market because
everybody buys a new phone every couple
of years it's pretty easy for you to
switch there's not a huge switching cost
so they need to provide a good
experience
and part of that is having low latency
on these services and also having low
error rates if a user starts getting
errors trying to share their photos
they'll probably throw out their phone
so on every request that they receive
they collect a bunch of tracing
information so who made the request what
the device ID was what the device type
was what the response could whether is
an error or okay latency and a log
messages are generated all that
information and that ends up
accumulating about twenty billion events
per day
this is about a month or two out of date
and it grew 4x since 6 months ago so it
could be 30 or 40 by now so accumulating
quite a bit of data for this tracing
information and they want to be able to
use this data in order to ensure a good
experience for their users so when they
roll out a new version of
their photo sharing app that starts
getting downloaded automatically by all
the phones out there and they want to
see immediately they release it on their
App Store is the error rate changing
maybe the people who happen to have this
particular model of phone start to get
an elevated error rate compared to
people the different type of phone maybe
it's correlated to a particular provider
like people on China mobile but not on
China Telecom you know there's many
different providers so they need to do
this analytics and they need to react
rapidly as something is it rolled out or
changed they do a bug fix on a service
in the backend as well because if they
can react rapidly they can stop the
rollout or fix the bug and that means
that much fewer of their customers will
have a bad experience if they were
waiting until the next day's report some
kind of a bulk load at midnight they
probably would have lost a bunch of
customers who had a bad experience for
an entire day and they also want to look
up individual records so once they start
to see some issue say the error rate on
the photo-sharing API is started to go
up they want to go look at individual
instances of this crash or this problem
and download the logs and look up the
information about that device what other
applications are on that device so the
engineer is trying to fix the bug really
want an interactive troubleshooting
experience they don't want to wait for
you know five or ten minute query every
time they want to look up an individual
point so the ability for crudité to do
individual point lookups is critical so
before cou do they had this pipeline and
it looks a little bit like the previous
diagram you'll notice the colors are
different on this slide this is a slide
delivered by one of the engineers that
show me at a previous conference so wave
their data source which is the api's
that are generating these events and
they were teeing that data to HBase and
also scribe into sequence files so
they're putting some in HBase so they
could do immediate lookups on the most
important data and then they're writing
the sequence files so they could do
faster ETL because the MapReduce and
stuff on sequence files will be faster
then they do this ETL convert data into
park' this is kind of hourly so the best
best guess is some data arrives one hour
later it might be available for
analytics and then they can run Impala
or other sequel engines on that park'
data and get good reports
so in the best case data is available
one hour later in the worst case they
have some kind of an issue in these
complicated ETL pipelines and it might
even be a day before the data is
available and they have a lot of issues
to around late arriving data where my
phone might be out of reception and some
apps have crashed and I come back into
reception and I end up uploading these
crash events from yesterday but they're
arriving today so they have a lot of
difficulty doing partitioning with this
scenario this is also exceedingly common
I've heard this from a number of people
in the community late arriving data is
just a huge hassle so with kudu this is
much easier you can just insert the data
whenever it arrives so their pipeline
now that they've switched to kudiye for
this application is a real-time ETL
pipeline so the data still arrives some
of the data can be directly ingested
into kudu so data that doesn't require
any ETL where you're just writing a very
simple log line they just write to kudu
using a java api so that's maybe a
millisecond or two before it's available
the other data that maybe need some ETL
like joining against a user's database
something like that they go using scribe
you get into Kafka and then storm
processes the data in Kafka and does the
real-time ETL so the particular
technologies there aren't really the
important bit you could use spark
streaming you could use flume a lot of
different options you could build the
main idea though is that this is a
real-time pipeline data arrives it's
written into this ETL system it performs
the ETL and a number of maybe less than
a second and right stick you do so the
typical latency of the real-time ETL is
sub second worst case maybe goes up to
ten seconds it's one of the servers is
garbage collecting or something but
you're never waiting hours or even a day
for the data to be available so then on
the right side of the diagram there
analysts can run Impala queries for fast
sequel against the data and see up to
the second data and then for other
workloads like individual point lookups
of devices and things they just use the
Java API directly for their applications
so this is a simpler architecture we
only have one storage system instead of
two and a much more real-time much
smaller window between data arriving and
being available all right so now I'm
kind of finished up on the use cases and
talk more about how it actually works
internally we won't have time for a real
in-depth discussion but I have office
hours later I can talk to you about it
we also have a paper you can go read
this paper it's kind of academic style
vldb style paper if you want the details
there right so the main entities include
that you have to worry about from the
users perspective our tables tablets and
tablet servers if you've read the
BigTable paper or the spanner paper this
will seem very familiar if you know
HBase just substitute the word tables
regions and region servers and you'll
get the same kind of general idea so we
take a table and we chop it into pieces
called tablets a tablet is a subset of
the table some subset of the rows and we
take those tablets and distribute them
around the cluster so that each server
in the cluster holds a couple chunks of
the tables so any individual table has
been spread out and that partitioning
can happen with two different algorithms
one is range partitioning which might be
say we're gonna take the data as split
it up by timestamp so today's data is on
this server yesterday's data is on that
server
two days ago somewhere else that's not
the best for some applications so we
have another option called hash
partitioning where we take each row we
compute a hash code of it using murmer
hash and then modulo the number of
buckets we want to split it into
so this basically sprays the data out
across all the clusters very evenly and
you can do that with pretty flexible
schemes we actually allow combining the
two and doing range and hash in
different ways you can get pretty
advanced but this is the main idea and
we also have a primary key on every
table so the primary key is a unique key
that allows you to do fast updates and
lookups by that key and the partitioning
doesn't have to be on the entire primary
key so this is different than a system
like HBase you could partition on a
suffix of the key for example so you
want to spread out the data by timestamp
but still do fast look ups by hosts
metric and timestamp so there's a lot of
flexibility we call this feature
flexible partitioning because we're
super creative naming and it lets you do
a lot of advanced thing
but the basic idea here is that we'll
spread your data out and you have a lot
of control over how that works so once
we spread the data out it's also
important to replicate the data so each
one of these tablets is replicated using
an algorithm called a draft consensus
anybody here familiar with raft or seen
paxos anybody nope access okay so very
similar algorithm this is part of a
general family of algorithms called
consensus algorithms and basically the
idea here is you have three different
computers three replicas of this tablet
and the algorithm ensures that they
agree on something they reach a
consensus so the agreement here is the
order and content of which operations
have happened in the entire history of
that tablet so when we insert a bunch of
rows one of the the server's is going to
act as a leader and sort of sequence
them and say this is the order that they
got inserted in here are the rows and
then run this algorithm to ensure that
everybody agrees yeah these rows were
inserted in this order when that
algorithm is complete we know that the
three replicas are completely
synchronized and if one of them crashes
we can just failover immediately to one
of the other ones so typical failover
times are less than five seconds you
could probably tune down your failover
times if you really need it faster
failover but this is pretty sufficient
for most applications and because we're
running the replication up at our level
in this kind of database log we actually
don't need a distributed file system
underneath so there's no dependency of
kudou on any other storage system you
can just deploy kudou on some nodes
you're good to go
you don't need HDFS you don't need
zookeeper everything is built-in so the
other process in addition to the tablet
servers is the master so the master is a
metadata server for the cluster you can
think of it almost like a phone book or
a directory so it does a couple simple
things the first keeping track of which
tablets exist once they split up a table
into tablets we need to know where they
are
the second is which tables exist their
schemas their metadata information who
created them that kind of thing and the
third is policy decisions so load
balancing if the server crashes we need
to make a new replica somewhere
Cattleya pick where well it's easiest to
centralize the policy if you put it in a
single place like the master you can be
a lot smarter about these policies but
notice it doesn't say anything about
data here it's only metadata so no data
ever flows through the master that means
it's not a bottleneck it's just small
amounts of metadata caches everything in
memory and the typical response times
for a request from the master are under
100 microseconds so it's very very
efficient so a sort of diagrammatic
approach is the best to understand this
we have here a client on the top left
and it's wanting to read or write a row
so it's saying I'm gonna write the row
called T lip con maybe it's a user's
table and it goes to the master and says
hey where is T lip con it responds with
some basic information saying it's on
these particular three servers so the
client can cache that information in
this meta cache it's okay if the cache
is stale it cañon know that find out
that it's stale and invalidate it later
and the client then sends the update
directly to one of the replicas which is
called the leader replica this leader
follower thing I won't get into today
but basically this is an online elected
kind of thing it's not like you have to
configure one as the leader one is the
follower so find the leader send it to
it and that will perform and replicate
the update and a subsequent update we
don't need to go back to the master you
already have the information in the
cache so the clients now connecting
directly to the tablet servers for reads
or writes all right last sort of bit
about the internals I wanted to cover a
columnar storage anybody here familiar
with Collin or storage Oh quite a bit ok
I'll move quickly through this since it
seems like a lot of hands went up here's
an example table this is a Twitter
firehose table so all the tweets we're
showing just four columns it probably
has 50 maybe a hundred columns we have
the tweet ID the username the creation
timestamp and the actual tweet text and
the traditional database what's called
row storage will store the data on disk
in basically the same order you see it
on the screen you can imagine like a TSV
file where you have the first row
completely then the second row
so columnstore doesn't do that it
actually takes this entire column of
tweet IDs and puts it in its own file
and similarly for the other three
columns so why would we do this
initially that seems like a kind of bad
idea because when we go and we're gonna
read this row we have to go read four
different files seek the disc four times
where you construct the row
it seems pretty expensive and in fact on
spinning disk this is much more
expensive because you have to go seek
four times but going back to the
beginning of the talk the hardware
trends mean that sikhs are no longer
that expensive if you care about random
access just by a flash disk or by a lot
of RAM and the Sikhs don't cost you
hardly anything so it's not that bad
anymore so why is it actually good I
mean not bad is one thing but why is it
good so let's look at the sizes of these
different files the time stamps are
pretty small maybe a gigabyte each
because they're just fixed length
integers username might be bigger
because it could be a long username and
the text is probably the largest
probably orders of magnitude larger than
the tweets 200 gigabytes here and then
you're an analyst and you come along and
want to do select count star where
matches a particular username like news
y combinator but think about what you
need to read to serve this query you
don't care about the tweet text you
don't care about the creation timestamp
etc you just read the user name column
which is only two gigabytes so you're
only reading two gigs of i/o instead of
having to read all of the data which
would be 200 gigs of i/o so you're
reading a hundred times less data and
your query will go 100 times faster so
that's obviously a really big benefit
and it turns out that this kind of
pattern shows up in almost every
analytic query you're usually not doing
analysis over all of your columns you're
usually picking some aggregating some
filtering some so you get really big
speed ups from this kind of design the
other big advantage is compression so if
we look at the creation timestamp you'll
notice that the first four five digits
of each of these is the same and we can
leverage that and store instead of the
entire timestamp which might be 64 bits
store the differences between each
successive entry and the differences can
be stored in maybe only 17 bit
so this is 4x compression by just doing
subtraction there's a question here sure
yeah so right now we're not smart about
picking the encoding so his point is
that this is a thing called differential
and in bit packing is the type of
encoding there's others called run
length coding dictionary coding there's
like a double delta diff thing there's
all these different ways we could be
smart about determining automatically
which one to use today we're dumb and we
make the users say here's a column you
should use RLE so we allow the option to
specify it but it's not automatic yet
the sort order is the primary key
because we need to sort by primary key
in order to look up by primary key so we
don't like Vertica allows you to have
different projections and different sort
orders we don't have that kind of
feature right so I was saying the
original timestamp is 64 bits each the
differences of timestamps are only 17
bits and this is super fast to compute
because this is a single subtraction
operation turns out that modern CPUs
have these things called sim D
instructions which is single instruction
multiple data so with one CPU
instruction we can actually compute
eight differences at the same time in
one cycle so this makes it very very
efficient it's basically free to do this
kind of compression and you say a 4x
disk space and this four X is actually
conservative a lot of use cases can
actually get down to a bit or less than
a bit per row things like time stamps
here time series values a lot of people
collect metrics and they collect a
metric once the second or once every 15
seconds from some value that basically
doesn't change
like what's the heap size of my java
process it's actually just flat like
almost all the time until the GC happens
so we can run length code that and get
that down to basically no storage cost
so this saves you a lot of space and by
saving space we're also saving on
bandwidth when we do a query so we're
not needing to read as much data from
the disk
we're not needing to read as much data
through the CPU everything can be a lot
faster all right starting to wrap up I
wanted to quickly show a couple inning
I'm not going to read the syntax that's
a little boring but we do have spark
data source integration you can download
the slides later and find out the FBI's
particularly we also have Impala
integration with new sequel support so
you can create a table you can insert
update delete Map Reduce of course if
anybody still is a MapReduce user here
alright so moving on to the performance
again I'll move these quickly you can go
study the slides on your own time I want
to leave time for questions so TP CH is
a pretty standard analytics benchmark
it's a suite of about 22 queries and
here we've got a cluster that's actually
large enough that the entire dataset 100
gig data set fits in RAM so you might
say this is cheating my argument is that
as ram gets larger and as Storage
performs more and more like Ram this is
going to be the important factor how
well does your storage and query
processing framework perform when
querying in RAM data most of your
current analytics where someone's really
interactively waiting will be coming
from very fast or Ram storage so we
compared kudu versus Parque and using
Impala as the same query engine for both
queries and we expected CUDA to be a
little bit slower and we're surprised
that actually was a bit faster 30%
faster geometric mean so that's not a
guarantee all workloads will be faster
we're not trying to beat Parque we think
Parque probably will be faster in the
long run we just had a couple
optimizations that we did that they
haven't done yet so the main takeaway
here is for analytic workloads kudu is
not a big trade-off versus using the
Best of Breed current technologies
comparing versus doing a similar query
on HBase we used Phoenix to query HBase
and these are log scale graphs you can't
really read the numbers probably but on
average about 20 times faster and some
query is 100 times faster or more 120
times faster the one query where Phoenix
was fastest is a single row lookup and
that's because Phoenix is really
designed for OLTP not analytics Impala
which were used for query and kudu is
designed for analytics so there's a lot
of fixed cost of starting a query a
single row lookup not very efficient
through Impala
and the last benchmark is no sequel
style access so why CSB is a
standardized measure mark for no sequel
stores and I'll let you look at the
slides on your own time but basically
the takeaway here is we're not as fast
as HBase if you have a no sequel
traditional random access only
application HBase might be twice as fast
might be four times as fast but we're
not talking about twenty times faster so
yeah we're taking some trade-off on our
no sequel performance but we're getting
a hundred times faster on our analytic
performance so that's the trade-off that
a lot of people are willing to take
so if I've sold you on this and this
looks exciting to you we're an open
source project we've got a beta out our
latest release should be coming out in
the next couple of days the xiaomi use
case i mentioned already in production
so even though we're beta we haven't had
like data loss or a lot of instability
they occasionally will find a problem or
a new bug but it's actually as stable as
a lot of 1.0 ZAR in my opinion and we're
part of the Apache foundation so if you
want to become a committer join us we're
happy to have more help here's a bunch
of logos the kind of NASCAR slide early
adopters contributors of kudu so it's a
small project still there's only maybe
nine or ten companies on the slide
probably a bunch more that haven't given
me permission to use their logo yet but
there are people using it it's not like
a science project so if you want to use
it check out our website get CUDA oh I
also have some cool stickers here if
you'd like
that say get kudu an i/o so you can
remind it about this every time you open
your laptop we also have a VM so you can
just download and play with it super
easy to get started and if you want to
develop with us everything we do is
public it's open source you can look at
our code reviews comments on our bugs
file new bugs join our mailing lists
we'd love to have more people involved
in the community even if it's just a
hobby for you that'd be great so I think
we've got about five minutes for
questions I don't know who's who's
running the questions but I'm happy to
take some if we have time
so is Impala Kanna aware of the primary
index and able to do smart things like I
started merge joins or efficient count
this thing on the primary key no yes and
no Impala is not aware of the primary
key yet that said if you do a select
star where a primary key equals
something it will push down the
predicate into kudu and kudu is aware of
the primary key so we're not gonna scan
your entire table for that but we're not
smart enough to do sort merge-join
which actually could just be merged join
if you're merging two on the same
primary key so there's a bunch of
smarter join strategies and partition
strategies that once we push some of our
information back up into the Impala
optimizer we can make Impala a lot more
efficient
same thing with Co partition tables like
you might have many different tables
that all have a user ID you could
partition all of them on the same user
ID and make join just be local we don't
support that yet so probably like a
five-year roadmap of pulling all the
database tricks and putting them in yeah
so we don't have any secondary index
support at all and our self yeah yeah
what is a kudu a kudu is an animal that
looks quite a bit like this is it lives
in South Africa there's a greater kudu
and a lesser kudu another piece of
trivia is that there's a sport in South
Africa where they take the dung like the
actual proof of a kudu which dries out
and gets quite hard and they put it in
their mouth and compete to see who can
spit it farther so we can fit in doing
this for a kudu team off site but we
couldn't find any kudu done it's quite
an interesting animal there so I think
the last question is sort of part of
what I was thinking about which is you
know is the assumption that you're gonna
denormalize your data and put everything
like one big table or or our joins
actually relatively performance yeah so
joins are relatively performance so the
TP CH workload that I showed the
benchmark of those are mostly joins
there's two queries in there that aren't
joins the rest that twenty others do
have joined some of them are five six
weigh joints so they're relatively
performant but I wouldn't go all the way
like the fully denormalize
you know classic 1980s database design
where you say instead of a date column
I'm gonna have a date ID and join
against the dates table like I think
that gets into the Phillies territory
but probably would be more denormalized
than then you'd normally do an Oracle or
something so somewhere in between
probably following the normal best
practices of a Hadoop based data
warehouse so we don't explicitly support
the ability to say replicate data on all
nodes you can change the replication
vector on a per table basis so in theory
if you have 80 nodes in your cluster you
could say replicate those table 80 ways
rights to it might become pretty slow
when you're actually trying to fan out
or write and run consensus over 80 nodes
we haven't tried it but please try and
report back and Paolo would not so it's
not smart enough it would still do a
kind of dumb thing so again there's a
lot of areas where we can have Impala
know more about how kudu is distributing
data and use that to optimize so
optimizing the joy is I think harder
because it needs to provide a location
of the data but I think still the
providing statistical information as a
like cardinality of the column or
connect of this come within this range
that kind thing it is used for to
optimize the Guru PI so the thing that
is like imply or yeah that's another
thing that's in our plan but haven't
been done yet so Impala has a function
called compute stats which is
implemented fairly naively it just scans
your entire table and then writes down
the stats in the meta store so if you
compute stats on the table Impala will
then use that for join and cardinality
estimation we could ourselves internally
keep estimates of cardinality so it's
something that's on our roadmap but
because there already is a way to do it
today it's kind of far on our roadmap do
you work on presto right yeah how do you
hear it yeah so if you are interested in
having a presto kudu connector yeah
it'll be a really useful thing for you
right all right I think next first sort
of major version will support the cost
based optimizations yeah three stories
needs to provide that yeah so this is
something that would be great to add
haven't prioritized it because there's a
workaround now but if you want to add it
it'd be great thank you